ciao a tutti buongiorno proviamo a
immaginare che sia possibile oggi giorno
fini geografici né amministrativi
proviamo a fare una cosa quasi
impossibile sembrerebbe al giorno d'oggi
cioè dovremo provare a demolire
l'insufficienza culturale che ci lega al
mondo di oggi
badate bene che esattamente come
gianluca cadeddu anch'io sono un
giurista e per tutti i giuristi quando
si scrive quando si parla ogni singola
parola ha un significato molto preciso e
dovremmo ritornare nel mondo in cui le
parole contano e non poco
faccio un passo indietro quando ero
giovane metà degli anni 90 si finiva la
scuola quelli che se lo potevano
permettere avevano modem a 56k così
ironia
vi ricordate è uno di quei computer
giganteschi per chi era un utente non
programmatore come possa essere io
l'utilizzo del computer e della rete era
accedere alla posta a tiscali a provare
a fare qualcosa per intenderci e siamo
verso il 95
siamo avanti di un paio d'anni la rete
esisteva ma non era ancora la rete zeppa
dalla roba che usiamo noi ci insegnavano
che se volevamo trovare qualcosa in rete
oltre che usare la posta
dovevamo essere bravi con le tecniche di
ricerca vi ricordate ricerca balljana e
via discorrendo
e se non usava le virgolette che cosa lo
spazio alla virgola il termine è magari
anche l'inglese era meglio perché i
documenti in italiano in altre lingue
erano pochi
non è che si trovasse poi più di tanto
facciamo un salto avanti
entriamo in era google per intenderci
da quel momento in poi invece succede
con le macchine e con la rete l'esatto
contrario cioè succede che non siamo noi
a dover cercare qualcosa in rete ciò che
ci serve
ma siamo di fronte a un sistema di
macchine è a una rete che
contemporaneamente imparai ci
restituisce quello che a noi serve dalle
nostre stesse ricerche ci siamo di
fronte a una rete ea delle macchine
che in sé sono auto apprendenti stesso
sviluppo ha avuto la logica di software
io non c'è qua non sono un software ista
non sono un programmatore ma un tempo è
ancora per molto
c'è un modo ordinario di scrivere i
codici anche se si sta evolvendo oggi
per l'appunto sapete si parla di cripto
monete di block chain che sono logiche
di programmazione diverse ora stanno
iniziando a cercare di fare dei
programmi dei software che hanno il
codice sorgente che è fatto come il dna
del corpo umano quindi non delle catene
infinite ma delle piccole porzioni
all'interno delle quali c'è tutto ciò
che serve per ripetere le operazioni e
per eseguire le operazioni gli stessi
materiali di cui si studia materiale
anche di nuova generazione di cui si
studia si è studiata la prima nasconda
la terza vita la quinta la quarta
scusate dimensione dei materiali oggi a
livello industriale non più ricerca si
studia la quinta dimensione dei
materiali quindi del di nuovi materiali
molto evoluti che incorporano dei
software altrettanto evoluti per
riprendere l'esempio di prima quello che
per chi come me e degli anni 70 80
quello che per noi era insalata di
matematica caro simone oggi e
cibernetica applicata
il mondo è cambiato ecco se non
ragionare più dentro il concetto dentro
lo schema che è proprio di tanti
bisognerebbe che i territori perché
quando parliamo di crisi non bisogna
parlare di sistemi parliamo di persone
parliamo di territori delle persone che
vivono nei territori e quindi
bisognerebbe che gli stessi territori e
le stesse persone all'interno dei
territori ragionassero in maniera altra
prendente ed è importante il passaggio
perché è la differenza tra esistere e
non esistere paragonerei a questo punto
il concetto di crisi normalmente
utilizzato che vorrei destrutturare
a un altro ambiente che mi e vi è molto
noto che quello del mondo della
creazione di nuova impresa innovativa o
meno che siano
proviamo a trovare un paragone tra la
sedicente crisi che ci vendono è il
fallimento di una start up
capite bene che siamo in due emisferi
totalmente differenti questa crisi
sembra monolite inattaccabili
inaffondabile immutabile senza risposta
dall'altra parte abbiamo il sistema di
fallimento di una start up di un'impresa
che se uno guarda lo storico degli
ultimi 50 anni nelle varie evoluzioni
industriali in realtà dai problemi che
hanno avuto le start up dei problemi che
hanno avuto alle imprese dal fallimento
delle imprese sempre nato qualcosa di
positivo
chiediamoci allora perché non è
possibile da un lato avere un sistema
perché è possibile un l'altra per un
sistema che dalla crisi non cambiano
migliora non apprende dall altra parte
invece abbiamo un sistema che dal
fallimento fa uscire una miglioria le
start up fanno pivot si dice cioè genere
non degli altri prodotti
il founder imparano cambiano diventa
qualcosa di diventa qualcosa di nuovo
perché succede questo sia nel mondo
delle imprese nuove che nel mondo delle
imprese consolidate
alzi la mano chi conosce un'impresa che
non sbaglia le imprese che non sbagliano
non esiste le pubbliche amministrazioni
che non sbagliano non esistono ma è sano
e fisiologico che cos'è che diventa
patologico nei territori le aziende le
imprese piccolo grandi le pubbliche
amministrazioni che commettono gli
stessi errori
ed è quello che succede ed è una delle
cose che permette di non scalfire la
crisi di cui parlavamo prima
allora non dobbiamo più commettere gli
stessi errori
vi chiederei anche se ci troviamo di
fronte una persona che dice non ho mai
fallito io non ho mai sbagliato e
naturale quantomeno vis consiglierei di
avere a che fare con quella persona
soprattutto dal punto di vista del
business
allora penso che
per citarne alcuni per non tediarvi uno
dei grandi difetti genetici delle cose
di cui parliamo sia la
monodimensionalità come tutti siamo
abituati a pensare le cose che usiamo i
luoghi dove abitiamo i percorsi che
facciamo solo ed esclusivamente nella
dimensione normale per cui ci hanno
insegnato a utilizzarli questo problema
della monodimensionalità ha secondo me
culmina nella peggiore delle
monodimensionalità noi siamo abituati ad
avere un atteggiamento fisico culturale
comportamentale di dipendenza siamo
dipendenti nel fare siamo dipendenti nel
non fare siamo dipendenti nel pensare e
siamo dipendenti del subire modelli
economici che non ci appartengono per
niente siamo dipendenti nell'avere un
modello di sviluppo territoriale che non
ci appartiene che è la copia della copia
della copia per dirla alla bersani di
mille rinunce bersani in cantante
ovviamente e allora bisogna sbagliare
bisogna uscire dalla dimensione
bisogna accettare trovare cercare le
molte più dimensioni che ogni singolo
oggetto ogni singola situazione può
avere e provarle e sperimentarle e
fallire generale delle crisi generale
degli ostacoli perché che cos'è che
rende unico un territorio se non la sua
specificità che cos'è che rende unico
un corso di studi un'esperienza di vita
un amore un'amicizia un'impresa se non
la particolarità la particolarità da che
cosa è data se non la vita al di fuori
di un binario se non la vita al di fuori
dello schema ordinario che ci impongono
allora capita bene che per questo che
dico che i territori che le imprese che
i cittadini che le pubbliche
amministrazioni devono cambiare
dimensione devono essere dei sistemi
auto apprendenti devono essere
perennemente in fase di out of the box
di rottura degli schemi fino a che non
avverrà questo percorso non riusciremo
ad invertire la rotta
però vi chiedo non riusciamo invertire
la rotta crisi ma qual è l'alternativa
qual è l'alternativa cioè dove ci porta
non affrontare un percorso diverso dove
ci porta non assumerci la responsabilità
di non intraprendere una strada di
cambiamento la strada di ricerca di
un'altra dimensione
voi direte se non cambiamo ci
schiantiamo no vi rassicuro ci siamo già
schiantati questa società è già
schiantata il sistema attuale già
schiantato sotto tutti i profili 50 anni
di storia repubblicana hanno massacrato
qualunque cosa voi possiate prendere
mare acqua laghi fiumi giustizia
pubblica amministrazione e già
massacrato quindi serve altro c'ero e
passare un'altra dimensione sarebbe
risvegliare riscoprire attraverso il
cambiamento la specificità l'unicità e
necessaria la vocazione delle persone
perché ciò che distingue dalle servivi
dal no dall essere molto più simili agli
oggetti fisici è necessaria la vocazione
dei territori perché siamo i territori
diventano terreno di conquista degli
altri mentre i territori non dipendenti
riescono e possono trovare la propria
vocazione che deve fare il paio con la
vocazione delle singole persone che ci
abito o che ci vogliono abitare o se il
territorio diventa attraente quelle
persone che possono andare ad abitare
nel territorio non c'è né ci deve essere
differenza ad esempio tra la sardegna o
altre zone attualmente sembrerebbe più
attraenti vanno riscritte le priorità
una volta trovate le vocazioni una volta
trovate le specificità riscritte le
priorità di fronte alla diseguaglianza
qual è il concetto che unifica tutte le
sfide di cui abbiamo parlato
sarò banale un po retrò grado ma rimane
sempre la sostenibilità che è
esattamente come innovazione esattamente
come degli a 90 sviluppo locale vengono
usate per sbandierare un concetto
vengono usate
nelle varie performance pubblico private
quando si vuol fare un convegno ma
rimane ancora lì per superare la
diseguaglianza o abbiamo una società più
sostenibile un ambiente una sanità più
sostenibile una finanza più sostenibile
e più etica o probabilmente anche qua ci
manca un pezzetto della sfida non
necessariamente tutti i territori devono
essere uniformati omogenei spalmati su
quella non dipendenza di cui dicevo
prima
altro tema rilevante in questo passaggio
è la differenza tra integrazione anche
qua l'integrazione delle culture ma
perché non parliamo di interazione tra
mondi perché non parliamo di interazione
tra popoli perché non parliamo di
interazione tra culture che cosa
dobbiamo già integra siano già integrati
il mondo e unico le specificità
culturali sono note integriamo anche
questa la scelta di crescita non è una
scelta di adeguamento con la generazione
che abbiamo alle porte pronta ai
cosiddetti millennials noi riuscissimo a
non fare l'errore che ha fatto la
generazione che ci ha preceduto con noi
millennials sono quasi espulsi reietti
dai propri territori sono nati globali
sono cresciuti globali si sono fermati
formati globali hanno strumenti globali
pensano globale ma indistintamente sono
identici sono unici e vogliono tornare
la nostra generazione ha il compito di
traghettare questo passaggio ma non deve
fare l'errore di quella precedente a noi
ci dicevano i giovani sono tutto il
futuro è dei giovani ma anche in questo
caso era una bandierina era solo un
passaggio in realtà noi abbiamo gli
strumenti per interagire
con la generazione di millennials e per
insieme a loro superare le
monodimensionalità di cui sopra e
costruire quel tessuto di fiducia di cui
sopra sarde csfa come nel mondo fanno
quelli che utilizzano i software open
source in tutto il mondo ci sono persone
che generano pezzi di codice
la loro ambizione quale è condividerla
con quello di quell altro paese di quell
altra nazione di quell'altra geografia
che esattamente come lui contribuirà a
quel codice sorgente open source per
avere maggiori dati maggiore competenza
maggiore informazione e allora l'altro
pezzo è e allora oltre a l'interazione
serve condivisione per generare il
fiducia serve connessione dopo gesù
cristo nostro signore qual è la più
grande rivoluzione del mondo se non
internet
mi chiedo quello per uno strumento non
un fine
non è uno scopo è uno strumento oggi
l'infrastruttura primaria lo stesso
phasar decs nei territori cos'è sarde
xenon una base una facilitazione per il
dialogo tra le imprese nei territori che
cos'è altro se non la capacità di
mettere in connessione il potenziale
inespresso
l'impresa di palau con un'impresa di
macomer e via discorrendo
e lo fa su base fiduciaria lo fa sulla
base di stretta di mano io sono convinto
che il 20 mila euro in crediti che metto
a correre io
saranno gli stessi che l'ingegner agnese
ammetterà palau e così tutti gli altri
4mila iscritti nel territorio più
dimensioni di un'impresa più dimensioni
di un territorio più legami condivisione
connessi in rete con sistema di rete
auto apprendente per evitare
che nei territori ci sia stasi e quindi
ci sia sostenibilità sociale economica
aziendale ambientale e finanziaria è un
pezzo
certo è un pezzo è un'azienda è un spa
come sappiamo presente in 12 regioni
italiane l'anno prossimo in tutte e
venti e che a serramanna dalla lavorare
a 100 persone non è molto voi direte
nella media dei comuni italiani la
stragrande maggioranza dei comuni
italiani è il più grande datore di
lavoro nel proprio comune in alcuni
paesi in alcune città
succede diversamente non è necessario e
non dobbiamo sopravvivere all'incertezza
l'incertezza può essere dominata guidata
e veicolata più che residenti
facciamo un passo avanti proviamo essere
anti fragili cioè proviamo a diventare
una cosa migliore perché tutto cambia la
differenza dell'anti fragilità sta nel
fatto che è la differenza che esiste tra
un sistema vivo è un oggetto fisico
proviamo
il vento può alzare un incendio
purtroppo per noi o può spegnere una
candela ma non sono inevitabili nessuna
delle due situazioni possiamo imparare a
governarlo e possiamo imparare ad
apprendere nel progresso che generiamo
la crisi quindi secondo me è un abito
mentale e culturale prima di tutto che
io non voglio indossare e che non
indosso non è l'economia che fa la
società ma è la società che fa
l'economia è un'economia giusta
un'economia etica un'economia
un'economia presente il tanto che serve
è possibile e lo stiamo gia dimostrando
questa non è più neanche secondo me
l'economia della conoscenza come scritto
qualche giorno fa seminerà di economia
della creatività e se ci pensate bene
la creatività è anche la cosa meno
automatizzabile
esiste io sono convinto che la sardegna
ce la farà sono convinto che i paesi
della sardegna
ce la faranno fino a che il mio
cardiologo non dice il contrario all
ignoranza delle persone non mi demolisce
sono pronto io sono convinto che
conoscenza sia libertà
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]